je souhaite vous interpeller à propos de
la situation sanitaire au regard de
l'influence ça aviaire hautement
pathogène qui frappe durement nos
éleveurs et au-delà toute la filière
avicole pour faire face aux différentes
vagues depuis 2017 le gouvernement a
toujours été aux côtés des acteurs de la
filière pamillette via des
indemnisations massives en tant que
parlementaire landais je souhaitais
saluer cet effort constant au printemps
2017 le ministre de l'Agriculture
d'alors avait signé un pacte de
biosécurité avec la filière palmited à
foie gras créant ainsi des mesures
préventives et réglementaires cherchant
à réduire les risques de diffusion et de
transmission dans le sud-ouest de la
France entre le 15 décembre 2022 et le
15 janvier 2023 le gouvernement a mis en
place le plan Adour ayant pour but de
créer un vide sanitaire ce plan a permis
de limiter considérablement le nombre de
foyers d'épisotis permettant de relancer
le repeuplement
des volailles malgré les avancées
conséquentes de la biosécurité
l'épisotis se répète ce généralise en
France et en Europe mais fort
heureusement nous en trouvons désormais
un espoir avec l'arrivée prochaine du
vaccin
sans qu'elle ne devienne substitut de la
biosécurité nous devons envisager de
recourir avec 6 nations massive mais
celle-ci ne peut se mettre en place sans
l'aide de l'État qui doit soutenir la
filière avicole dans cette démarche
la vaccination doit se faire volailles
par volailles avec un coût unitaire du
vaccin très élevé en outre ils devront
on devra ajouter un monitoring post
vaccination particulièrement lourd et
onéreux et cela afin de garantir la
crédibilité et l'efficacité de la
stratégie vaccinale retenue compte tenu
de ces conditions décrites monsieur le
ministre envisagez-vous les mises en
place d'un plan visant à soutenir
financièrement nos éleveurs lors du
déploiement de la vaccination je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Marc fenault ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés Fabien Lainé merci
de votre question qui me permet de faire
le point sur l'influence arrière d'abord
le point d'étape sur l'influenza
elle-même
je vous rappelle que à l'issue de
l'épisode de l'année dernière nous
avions eu plus de 1400 foyers nous
sommes à date avec un peu plus de 310
foyers ce qui est quand même alors je
pense à tous les éleveurs touchés pour
qui c'est parfois le deuxième le
troisième ou voir plus d'épisodes mais
c'est quand même une meilleure nouvelle
que l'année précédente alors que nous
nourrissions à date en tout cas que nous
nourrissions des inquiétudes l'an
dernier puisque on sait très bien que
l'influence a été restée endémique
premier élément deuxième élément on a
été à la hauteur je crois compris de
l'accompagnement des éleveurs et compris
des en termes d'indemnisation puisque
plus d'un milliard d'euros ont été
prévus pour l'indemnisation de la
période qui courait en 2021 et en 2022
et que nous avons remis en place le même
dispositif alors qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire désormais la première chose faut
saluer le plan Adour alors si vous avez
dit vous avez raison de salut l'action
du gouvernement mais c'est un plan qui a
été monté avec les éleveurs
et qui a été voulu par les éleveurs qui
étaient un plan au fond de
désensification c'est-à-dire dans les
périodes les plus à risque des 100
janvier de faire en sorte qu'on ne
repeuple pas tout de suite les élevages
pour éviter les périodes où il y a le
plus de risques de contamination et ça a
plutôt marché puisque dans la grande
zone Sud-Ouest il y avait en moyenne 300
foyers il y en a que 20 cette année qui
sont constatés on n'est pas complètement
au bout de l'épisode mais enfin en tout
cas on peut constater que ça a été dans
le bon sens l'objectif c'est de
prolonger ces mesures là et donc on aura
un accompagnement financier ça nous
paraît important de le faire premier
objectif deuxième objectif de penser la
même chose sur d'autres zones de
regarder comment on peut le faire y
compris pour pas préserver le patrimoine
génétique qui sert pour les canards qui
est en Pays de Loire et qui est menacé
par l'influenza en pays Loire du fait
des épisodes récents puis troisième
élément j'y viens la vaccination nous
avons les résultats à la vaccination qui
vont arriver d'ici le courant du mois de
mars on a commencé à déployer un plan
parce qu'il faut faire de la logistique
de la prévisibilité sur ces sujets là on
a j'ai annoncé que le gouvernement
l'État prend en charge une partie de la
vaccination
et deuxième élément on a besoin de
travailler sur les normes de commerce
pourquoi parce qu'il y a des échanges
internationaux qui sont soumis parfois à
des règles vaccination faudrait pas que
ça vienne opérer nos capacités d'export
voilà les sujets sur lesquels nous
travaillons merci beaucoup monsieur